welcome to another edition of a Mike
comer plays the people I'm alongside
chess expert Katelyn yup Caleb dumby yep
so today I will be taking one minute
no increment no delay challenges rated
matches alright so let's kick it off
I'll just create a game one Oh in real
time all right there we go
so Caleb please don't help me too much
okay will do will do you don't need you
don't need my help okay good good so I
was I was wondering about this how many
moves can you pre move ahead in this
game only one Onley chess time okay so
where are other programs can you do
multiple yeah I believe on a chess calm
you can pre move like up to like 10
moves ahead and it's kind of insane okay
yeah but don't get so just one cuz I was
trying to do that in some of my games
and it wasn't working out was just
wondering if it was just me or what's
going on
yeah the would say well that's you okay
so now I know oh you're see if I have
fun
yep it's gone okay oh god it'll need it
yeah
so let's see what's going on this guy
gonna checkmate me and eat you issues
yeah good luck oh I beat ya good good
good good good
yeah one of my best friends on chess air
goes Mike Oh No alright alright wait we
survived we survived and now I'm done
now I'm gonna crush him so I'm down on
time down in position and it's not
looking very good but my queen is now
protecting my file so what's going on g
6g 6 is falling all right see a g6
didn't need them hidden enum and now I
trade everything still doing okay
somehow someway right yeah I believe
you'll survive I'll survive if I win
this this is gonna be something okay was
something
maybe I'll just take a draw who maybe
maybe uh-oh he's gone for checkmate
desperate times desperate times no how
did that happen oh he took with the
bishop instead of the rooks a very
sneaky very sneaky
all right after seeing that who wouldn't
want to challenge me all right go first
games always the toughest you know yeah
get warmed up yeah we're right I guess
probably for playing for seven hours you
know so he had those yeah I had getting
developed playing pretty slow today
hello tasty waffle one navin 7:00 to
8:00 all right every night this is what
we need this is what we need this is
what we need now we just need to bring
it home it looks like he's got a pretty
big attack here actually somehow I've
got a second all back
Luke D hazard back good to see you good
to see it yes I get to trade the Queens
and this guy's playing awfully fast here
it's kind of kind of intimidating he's
kind of intimidating I don't like my
chances he's got to take with that phone
I just gotta get to work papa Bishop up
a bishop all right all right I'm missing
this the whole time thank you for not
telling yeah well that's kind of beats
feats the purpose of this I'm happy to
just SPECT it all right there we go
unless he plays he did play e5 just move
hello PJ
rutkowski difficult names in the chat
shucks alright do anything dependence
guy alright we got it we got a penned
check the rookies dead
take take all right we got a draw at
least out of this that's good let's try
to get more huh all right see pong go to
fame fame and fortune fame and fortune
with the c-pawn oh oh oh oh oh that was
close it was close
good thing he resigned beautiful
technique is there any way that I could
just get a clean like yeah yeah yeah
help me out scale cuz he alright I'm not
under promoting that's not my style
alright I'd want the what though the
Queen you know wrote Queen always always
thank you thank you thank you alright
alright so we got it we're on the board
we're on the board that guy's probably
pretty mad because he was playing really
fast but somehow I love I love to play
these guys where they don't know the
rating so that's good there's be a lot
of confidence when I play them you never
know
hey DJ we're only doing one plus zero
for the moment so if you want to
challenge this challenge one plus zero
castle alright let's get going here on
all the lights all of the lights quiz oh
my god this is it this is that are
squares to how I can this guy Chuck
we're crushing this guy we just go for
it right
go for it okay I don't know to go for it
just keep checking until I'm not there
though oh there must be a check name
there must be oh oh here we go wait wait
he's Keith gave me his coin let's just
take it okay absolutely
Chuck get really close uh-oh oh thank
god I'm not gonna win there I hate being
in a windmill nobody enjoys that
all right extra queen but it is tough it
is tough
let's see if I can checkmate him somehow
I might be playing the quad state DJ LZ
it's good to see this might be checkmate
coming up here it's looking like it come
on checkmate
that's close where oh where is that's -
Oh a stick two victories in a row he got
a streak going I got a streak going
who's the lowest roll yeah here we go
Nathan Nate
yes or no all right I'll stay for the
quads just for you a DJ yeah so tonight
we have of course the Friday action
quads and tomorrow we have the Saturday
night blitz with a guaranteed $200 prize
one so even if it snows like it's
supposed to guess what I'll be there and
you can challenge me seven rounds and
guaranteed prize fund of $200
what a deal what a deal alright so you
better come by rain sleet snow doesn't
matter I'm too good I'm too good
maybe I'll oh he didn't let me do unto
him what I did to me I was gonna sack I
was gonna sack he gets another chick or
you can just give me a bishop taking all
the pieces yep now work takes night
coming up of course no all right here we
go
no I get to have some fun but I can't
Castle illegal hate it when that happens
yes
think about putting my bishop on h3 but
instead I'll do this checkmate the long
thing ooh
Queen to dethrone Queen to d3 would have
been a really good move because a dang
it would have prevented that and life he
ever put his rook down to attack me I
could just checkmate Oh high-level stuff
I didn't think about Queen D this is the
only us
hello cheesy chess doing well I've won
my last three games Oh big challenge
this game but here we go we're gonna try
to play a chess that's not the
commentary that is just something I play
now what is d4 c5 called Caleb the old
Benoni
like played the old banana hold the
money
it gets Perry every time and literally
every I'll look you up there I'll never
be able to play it again I'll let you in
on the now uh-oh he wants my able on
better save it better save it now this
yep perfect just as I drew it up got
those Queen side weaknesses I'm Way
better than this guy yeah bishop and
getting so this is it alright check
always check don't want to give them
that so this should be a draw just don't
mess it up right yeah you fine yeah
should be a draw if anyone has chances I
think it's you yeah I've got the chances
he's got notes it's it's gonna all come
down to oh well
a blunder that's okay but I got ideas I
got ideas yeah I still have ideas a
three is dangerous a three is dangerous
dangerous he's got a passer oh I gotta
take that way but here we go here we go
here we go oh I only got one second
uh-huh if you had more time this is big
this is huge
always promote I know almost to come
back in the day yeah Jay King ran I knew
I was better than him but why not pull
it off could not pull it off my good
good game good game good game
all right Robin Jenna he got a challenge
me to rated you're not gonna sneak one
in one plus overrated challenges hello
Mathias welcome welcome
he saw it somehow this is not good
oh can you just take it in the end I
didn't take it all right it so much
space so much braking in the center
breaking yeah here we go here we go when
they attack you you just attach that
Saturday even if it's even if it's no
good but now I got you oh yeah you were
smart you were smart not to take that a
free pawn free pawn I'm in check
I'm in check all right yeah I'm going
there anyway
he better not play Bishop d3 okay good
got the pawn I got the fun that's all I
need that's all I need let's just try
and try and do something here try and do
something all right Christopher
hello chess kid I still have the back
row
checkmate possibilities so I'm not gonna
give up yes Nadia chances not gonna give
up yes I'm gonna go under oh there it is
oh but it's not quite now it's just a
rough went from down to cleaned it down
the rook take it take it
maybe you'll hang some fork Oh check oh
I blew it I blew the fork I blew the
fork I don't know if it was gonna happen
anyway yeah I have big big plans with
that alright take that and now we go to
the stalemate now when you're going for
stalemate never take the bish up okay
get in the corner hang out in the corner
push them
I don't wanna get checked by the cleane
well hey guys
maybe I should more sex sure that
shouldn't have walked into mate oh well
oh well alright stilt still hold steady
with these ten challenges 1320 yeah what
was that guy's rating he had a question
mark yeah okay yeah that guy would stay
yeah he's bound for master it was
question mark people they're scary yeah
you never know you never can tell it
doesn't help when you drop a queen to a
discovery that does hurt see for this
time oh yeah yeah well that last game
right I pre moved that b4 c4 Knight c3
and then that Knight c3 I guess over
King yeah I got you alright free pawn
alright I'm ahead in time and position
so time up here so I have no excuses
this game no excu but I'll figure out
something f6 alright now I really like
my extra pawn looking around I just stay
off the light square and he wants to
trade once the trade on my terms
okay my terms whoa he's getting too
close it's getting too close
alright there it is it that's game
nothing he can do now just nothing he
can do I need to get my King in the game
play c5 that's fine okay okay
nope saw it
oh my god I almost play a bedroom yeah
it was late night check and then think
of my H point could just run away
forever
I've been disaster it would have been
let's just figure this out my name is
Caleb I'm glad to be joining Mike today
be really careful here that do anything
all right
three pawns extra night complete faith
in you thank you leave
yet another one yeah yeah given how to
get another one he's only doing one
minute challenges for the moment
well stalemate the little minute
yes oh no oh boy on time that was a
tough tough complicated checkmate I
would have had a big round so glad I'd
been glad I didn't have to all right
let's see is there anybody good 1994
this could put you over the top so this
is a big game for sure win again so when
again number two not as good as the
first ones like that's alright we'll see
we'll see
oh they didn't go for that all right I
just play like you I just play like you
see how you like it see how you like it
thanks for the welcome cave cave econ
I'm gonna be around I think I'm gonna be
on the stream yeah so you'll be seeing
more of me hopefully now why do people
like to put their bishop on h1 cuz they
don't want to trade with you they trade
with you then your queen gets in well
that was a big mistake
it was a big mistake for him for him
okay okay all right now he's now he
thinks he's so good but little does he
know I got something something going on
but I want you to do that I want you to
do that force the issue force the issue
here we go here we go I need that yeah
right I'd rather oh he's on he's on
get this nobody wants the rook I don't
want to trade Queens either that Porter
up nobody wants them one minute only for
the moment razor one middle one minute
only
yes complicated and what do you want to
do Oh big mistake business I'll close
the file you need to start checkmating
him I agree
desperate times don't need it either
look or the night there we go somehow
someway this is happening this is
happening it's happening
this guy must be like what happened he's
never seen Waialae this 1+5 I think he
actually lost points after 1986 all
right
it was 1996 all right Robin Johnson
let's see what you've got let's see what
you've got
Chauncey more question marks or always
take the pawn always take
got pressure actually gave them that
pressure all right say goodbye to your B
pawn shop right no matter what they
don't want and now your C pawn is gone
you don't need those other pieces right
he's a monster plus that's to even the
computer saying plus yeah the computer
knows it knows that a kid knows how to
count those pawns yeah give me a check
goading you into checking ma'am goading
you into it whatever whatever
alright now he's gonna give me a check
and feel so good you got 14 seconds to
find oh you missed it you missed the
check should I let you check me again
yep no I'm not giving you nothing all
right all right nothing for him Oh kind
of threatening a checkmate but it's not
Marcin wants you to say something nice
to the polish fans do you have anything
to say to our polish fans Mike stay warm
stay warm stay warm and pull
I guess that that'll we're 915 Mari
taking it to take a soda to take a break
what's that body a body will be in the
quads he'll be taking pictures and
there'll be a lot of fun and he'll be
here he'll probably be here for the
Saturday night blitz huh
Wayne sleet snow shining whatever no
matter what no matter what two hundred
dollar prize fun unconditionally
guaranteed it could just be me and you
seven game round-robin splitting them on
yep at least your dark squares yeah this
is not here comes oh here we go
cleaned it there Mohamed whenever you
hit get tempted to play up six always
look for a better move right now a lot
of people say been fine goal came up
with never play up six that was me that
was you that was he learned it from me I
never knew that cuz even my mom knows
never to play f6 and she's known that
since the 90s okay all right and she
doesn't know anything about chess so
does she teach it to you or the other
way around maybe I maybe I was playing
her and she shot okay and she like o of
six and Alex never never ever the origin
o my queen is hanging Oh Mark Braud I
was close so are you today
I really should have played queen two
there I got the checkmate these dark
squares these dark squares alright it's
all you you play play any check your one
it's hoping you would play that one yeah
another check Oh Knight to e8 check ok
Thank You Lee that was not checkmate
that would have been something that that
would have been checkmate well I've room
to run now what have been something
regardless yeah you don't see many
knight on the back row checkmate
you know there's a famous puzzle can you
construct a position where you play G
takes f 8 equals 9 checkmate in 6 moves
I was never good at stuff like that now
there's only one way to do it oh wow
only one way to do it alright look at
kappa blanka the century man alright i'm
playing kappa blanka right now let's see
if i can beat them so a lot of things
are like who's better kappa blanka or
somebody from this era so this this will
be the definitive response ok so you can
end all the debates who's better good to
hear somebody from a modern era or
Capablanca
and this will settle it this is settle
once and for all
I'm not castled that way I'm not castled
that way so I can attack you I don't
know let them know yeah yeah you better
not take that poison pawn what are you
doing I got something for that and
you're not gonna like this like I almost
want to pre move it
I almost yes
oh now you want to take it a little late
a little late now bish up there yeah
you're so predictable
he's so yes no I got that long day oh
did not see the rover or whatever you're
calling rocks move sideways can i snow
castle that's funny
alright alright we're going we're in
full stalemate position here hole
stalemate position got a couple more
pawns to get rid of and then you're
practically there you know I'll let you
have my Bishop I'll let you have my
bishop I'm not gonna walk in the
checkmate dang it
all right let's hurry up well good I
want you to check now once you check me
so bad
come on oh so I'm just as good as couple
of like so there it is
so people from the minor are just as
good as people from way back centuries
ago yeah yeah he got all cute with all
these bishop checks I'll attack you with
one Bishop with the rook I move it I
would take it with the other right same
thing with the king it's not dead easy
kappa blanka alright yes so that was a
good one that was a good one poor guy
poor folk I thought he was one of the
grades I'm down a size kind of dentist
sighs let's get an easy game after that
one we're only doing one plus Oh today
Muhammad rated rated one plus zero
nobody knows all right
oh oh I could get his rope Oh
dicks
I
watch out here just hoping I play Bishop
at six that's a good hope just there
that's good hope chest
sanal stuff yeah I Castle let's protect
this guy that week diagonal now I don't
know about this g3 move
I don't know about g3 alright so you
cannot castle right like his king stayin
in the Senate well maybe not
oh he's running what is going on oh my
god this guy could this guy could pull
off an amazing comeback here how did the
head result between me and Mike I don't
know do we have much of a I don't know
if we've ever played much of a match
history I pretty much remember all my
games I don't know if we've ever played
I know I beat you on a lead chess right
no that's a lie that's alive I we drew
oh it is a lie are you sure yeah Oh cuz
I'm the track meet you Oh Knight and
Bishop check me alright got a little too
fancy for my own good oh my goodness
there goes the Queen what Oh your flag
yeah this guy this guy scared me what
are you doing lesson one I don't know do
you ever remember us playing over the
board
I really don't unless we probably did
when I was younger but oh then I mean
that means I would have been the winner
oh is that it's very tough for me to
lose to lower rated players leave oh is
one plus Oh NIC just like today hello
LD BC
alright now maybe we will get to see the
color variation finally here it is
there's the official color very you
invented this yes alright so in the July
1998 chest life - nice Larry Evans has
come Alexis where's your king going this
he's gotta stay on you're just gonna
hang out right where you hang out
alright that's the plan
never seen this this kingside expansion
from the black learn something new every
day especially when you're watching
commerce I guess so deal I'm going this
way
alright got me in a pin out of the pin
out of the pin check no you can't check
me can't check this is actually pretty
good how you got out of it you got out
of there I don't want to do an
impression of Mike you don't need an
impression he's listened to the real
thing Oh big check coming up big check
coming up let's just a primo of it I 15
seconds 15 seconds it's just not get
back wrote checkmate Oh God that's a bad
girl checkmate if I've ever seen
here we go max protect who brought it
for a run
oh he's not even letting me run not even
letting me run huh oh you let me run
this way okay I'll run that way as far
as I can at least
ah free queen no wait
sesame squeezy got me he got me misery
played a few games with this person I
believe yeah very own Arthur okay he's
pretty good I'll see oh my goodness
let's see if he's good enough let's see
if he's good I don't know about all this
I do well from him I don't know what
he's doing
yeah somebody's trying to get in so
let's try getting in the bunker he's
trying to get in the bunker breaking
down the door breaking down the door to
watch this game you just got to see it
this was very scary very scary all right
[Music]
Chuck yeah no I got the check no I got
the check counter check what coupons
give me a check we've been invaded we've
been it looks like there had enough see
ya surprised visitors on the stream I
got the guys work back a stir and now
all I need to do is play a five this get
that gave me the spark I needed to win
it come back and win this is it
and you said Rob was good huh I thought
so I thought so
no what's going on do I bring this home
how does he bring it home gotta bring it
home I guess I can just win his rook
this way yeah yes I am resigned just too
easy for you Mike oh I've got scared
with all those people breaking into our
studio that it just made me just this
extreme focus
Dennis and Dennis are off the stream
today believe I don't think I did see
Dennis somewhere how many people we got
a man in a suit you know I'm on Hamilton
will be our grand master in residence
coming up it's true in early 2019 so
looking forward to that looking forward
to our big match protests League match
coming up Tuesday at 4:40 st. Louis time
it will be st. Louis Archbishop's with a
team I managed against the Montreal
chess press both of us have 21 and a
half points and we lead the league in
scoring and that's how we do it so that
would be a big match Ivan's Eric yes his
name okay so he'll be he'll be inter
bolter so I don't know if they're going
to be playing him from Gibraltar or not
so it'll be interesting but they do have
a secret free agent a niche Giri so
maybe he'll be playing on board one so
this is like a match of the Titans
coming up that's for 40 you can check it
out on a chest comm Danny wrench does an
excellent play-by-play analysis so it
could really really see a big big early
season matchup to see who will who will
contest for the top seed and if you get
the top seed in the divisional round the
first two rounds of the playoffs you get
drawed so pretty important to be a
number uh number one the Oh genius
r-right our Theo genius
does he want to play does he want to
play it's not connected or not could not
connected board game you had your chance
don't say don't say you didn't have your
chance you missed it missed it and any
time he challenges for now on I'm gonna
just exit
okay let's X out some of these casual
the people at the top have been
challenging the longest if you want to
help them out
Oh East 1985 all right I'll help you out
Sean blazer wants a game sorry son we'll
see what we can do we'll see what we can
do
this is not the comer variation but it's
close close it's even better
oh wow what's this about night to be
five whatever it hurt
I wasn't saying welcome let's check this
the show who's boss yeah now I owe he
does not want us nights looking like
that oh man I can't I can't resist I
know it's bad but can't risk yeah who
could resist who a good risk says to so
that's it what's it play Queen to b3
Queen of c1 whatever those dark squares
yeah oh here's dark squares well at
first it was yours but now now it's
yours no it's oh oh oh I've got it I've
got them all covered I got em all
covered hi I'm 300 points better in this
guy anyways he's lucky lasted this long
never saw that one coming never like
somebody wants to know if you've ever
owned an El Camino okay nope okay I got
answers that I was a big Chevy guy for a
long time I had a Chevy Chevy RS is that
a real thing and then then I used to
drive around with Chevy celebrity for a
long time that was my car but then it it
no longer ceased to exist and now I'm a
Ford truck guy Ford f-150 he might beat
me actually he might be this is not as
good as it used to be got time you've
got time I just need to start running
McKean around I just hope he doesn't
check meet me or something I needed that
alright if you want to give me pieces
I'll take them okay that's the deal
oh look at this my that would have been
my goodness just send us a challenge
oh yeah where's the Shawn blazer right
Nick risco wants the game to hear why I
changed me like 3-2 or something
only playing a Knick risco since you're
listening if if it snows too bad
tomorrow
you don't have to come in to run the
Blitz I got it I'll be here no matter
what so no he's got a really cool car
too Anna Crisco I almost wanted to buy
it but um he said the window doesn't go
down I like to blast the music and uh
listen to the radio of course so sorry
No Deal Nick risk Oh No Deal it was
close though it was close oh come on
it's no fun he should have taken my
night when he had a chance now I'm my
nights really comfortable really
comfortable now how do I win this that's
the question I guess I just start
running around I don't know what your
plan is but I probably should get a guy
over there
you could play Queen takes Knight and
that'd be something that'd be something
I'd be something I'm gonna take that
Jeep on it I don't know what I get out
of their queen that I win your queen I
did not very unfortunate alright just
keep chugging along and see what happens
he should take my pawn he doesn't moving
this pawn no well that's the end of that
and he's up on time oh my gosh I need to
play King to g2 here
hello big foot big food this guy's
pretty annoying here's gonna have some
tough one gotta break it open
I know it was my chance that was my
chance
alright here we go oh that was very all
right well times well time we've seen
this one before
oh is that draw that's uh that's a good
draw that's a good good a good result
for that match the dime on Ian once a
game if you're interested well let's see
if you did 100 standard rated Nick risk
oh and diamond down at the bottom there
he's a questionmark guy don't try that
good good good get good I'm not afraid
of any question mark I'm terrified
Oh probably free move too much that's
what happened last time I played that
one question
- and I have Alou stock the opening I
wanted but maybe he was preparing the
other opening maybe now he so now he's
ready for you right
I wasn't ready for this it's about ready
for this
got some space got some threats space
worked it worked test the game that's
why you came
that is the game is this Miko 89 is that
Nick risk oh no Nick risk oh is chess
worm OTB all right Nick risk oh here we
go here we go big mess big match
oh he stopped it you know exactly what I
was doing all you need is space and
threats space and threats alright
everything any new bounty hunt series
coming up oh yeah yeah yeah tease this
last time it will last time it was at a
ice rink this time it'll be on a diamond
so let's see if you can figure out what
that means can you figure out what that
means
I've got a few guesses alright I gave
you one
I'll give you one baseball Oh baseball
diamond how did he figure that one out
I'm pretty quick you know so it'll be
very exciting well a Kobe in play life
I'm not sure if we have a Kobe and as a
resident Jam coming up I thought a
Cobian already did play like he did
earlier hey like yeah it was the second
their first official one
it's not checkmate Nick risk oh you got
might work on a one yeah I don't even
need my work so beatnik risk oh that's
well that's unpretty uh pretty sad
pretty sad day pretty sad day I'm not
moving one of my rooks well maybe I have
to now the big task
don't Chuck hello say hi to everybody
welcome welcome your rook I guess you
didn't need it I'm gonna be [ __ ] I
already said big win why does Victoria's
oh my god we got 312 so we still gotta
look at still got some time to get top
guy there once a game he said no Jack
you're out cuppa blood you had your
chance we already determined everything
we need to determine I think I already
played that guy you've been waiting long
enough
let me coach maybe all right he's gonna
let's see if we can see you can see if
you can refute it see if we can refute
it what to do 9300 ja ja all right have
you waited that long for it oh you
blinked you blinked oh I missed them I
messed up I needed to play Knight to g4
mm-hmm now we place f3 it's a little
waiting oh my gosh this up that's okay
hey that's okay it's okay I was doing
terribly yet might get a little
checkmated but just a little bit
I got a pawn free pawn prove it prove it
right away
Oh is right uh-oh is right and my night
my night when I protects everything
check I want to do key stuff my nights
the man my night is the man
very spooky stuff I should have taken
the pawn when I had that chance
all right well oh there were the old
fashioned we missed Queen age six six
yeah this guy's always like a move
behind it seems like this is still scary
not out of the woods yet still firmly in
the woods how to stop Queen to wherever
checkmate nobody knows Queen g5 only way
just get out of that get out of there
he's right at night he's gonna have it
all you can have it all take it all take
it all take it
oh he was smart he was smart he was
smart you were close we're closing in ha
yeah I give me coast 89 credit money
then take the perpetual check our pet
perpetual earlier and yeah yeah he's
sacrificed really you really put put in
the effort you put in the effort all
right some guy named named razor is
talking a lot of big talk about anything
oh wait wait is he gonna take you on
that's him forget it forget her get it
abort he challenged me to uh oh it was
casual yeah yeah that's why they could
talk that's why you could talk big it
was just an exhibition match we're
playing for keeps here right no uh-oh
the Oh genius II had your chance where's
this clever king who ever came crash
they got lucky you got one okay but this
is a Danish Boros Webster windmill uh
part-time head coach that's his opening
yeah d3 d5 why not just push it face in
the world what more could you ask for
Oh oh my goodness so many threats I
don't even know what I want I guess I
have to take his rook rooks are good
yeah yeah that part's pretty good to the
pawn looked good
oh my gosh this guy's giving me
everything and you're afraid of these
guys with question marks yeah and
they're terrified yeah yeah sometimes
they're good Oh weed
do you guys have a hard time switching
between electronic and physical chess
boards no can be hard for some people
who learn to play online but I I don't
really have any trouble either yeah if
you want to send me some easy questions
yep feel free don't expect big big
answers but know
right this guy you you're just trying to
beat you at your own stalemate game I
think yeah not a chance
oh how is this not checkmate it is okay
good I was like come on I think you
already played Navin Navin it gives me
mantle bird EF more all right we get
game aborted game a boy he doesn't one
of the hurt Sesame Creed I think I
played you already way is this casual
nah that's right it's right now a cargo
plane will play rated 1 plus so only big
snowstorm coming back to st. Louis again
scary stuff now this is not the target
though last last week it st. Louis was
the target for the big snowstorm but I
think they're going to New England this
time around but we're in its path though
so we have to respect it still so I will
be I will be bunker down at the chest
campus all weekend so the Chess Club
will not be closing and we will have the
$200 unconditionally guaranteed say
night blitz coming up check it out check
it out yo
so do you have to work he thinks he's
got tactics
no no tactics pretty good alright okay
the bishop look back I don't have to
work this week oh good so he'll be safe
and sound will be no breathing it on the
roads for me good good good yes stay
home if you have to there's no excuse no
excuse the leap all right let's see if I
can just get a pastor and beat this guy
favorite chess books Bobby Fischer
teaches chess good that's for the kids
and then of course winning chest tactics
for juniors are free
students it's the orange book it's like
ten books it's really good and now I got
the tactic no I got that
I learned that from winning chess
tactics for for juniors it's only ten
bucks I'm a fan of Jeremy Simmons books
I liked the Complete Book of chess
strategy when I was starting out big
help big help
I'm also a big fan of Jeremy Salman I
actually got to go to a chess camp the
summer of 1997 and and as a prize I got
did well in a you know the end of the
camp tournament and I got the how to
reassess your chest by Jeremy Sullivan
so I was kind of stuck in a rut I jumped
from like 800 to 1333 really quick and
then might if kind of like balance there
for a second and then I read that book
and then by the time the state
championship rolled around in 1998 a
niche Giri even knows this story of
course I was 16 61 from 1333 to 1661 in
you know was very small amount of time
and of course I won the 1998 Missouri
scholastic state champion
all thanks to a Jeremy Stillman and we
have asked Jeremy sillman on my behalf
to come to the club and analyze games
but um unfortunately we could never work
it out but hopefully maybe sometime in
the future there's always hope there's
always hope but yeah he's one of my big
fans too Thank You Conrad for the game
he says it was an honor to lose it yes
yes as it always is I am the guy that
presented the Shirov attack video feel
free to check out all of our lectures on
YouTube but especially mine yes always
good to plug your own style lectures by
Caleb Desmond
now the first lecture you ever did right
you filled in for another chest bra
right that's right it was my first day
at the club first day Eric Hanson got
called away to a dinner and he just
handed me his chest bass notes he sent
me an email and said go teach this class
so right into the fire for me but it was
a it was a good time oh no Knight takes
f6 oh no I thought I had all figured out
I thought I had it all figured out oh I
always sing this one before there's only
one thing to do it's always a chance
never take the bishop never take the
bishop it's a trick
I might take his knight though gets you
closer to still me oh baby complete
that's no fun hey I don't know why you
got lucky you got lucky I missed I'm in
I thought I was being so cool I thought
it was being so I think Yusupov does
have some good bugs I haven't read them
though I'm not sure what the what the
rating range our accounts been at what
do you think the highest this accounts
been up to I've never got it up to 1800
all right let's try to do that all right
we're 1768 let's let's try to get the
1800 in the next half hour here gotta
impress luminous lion okay I don't think
we're gonna get it by beating 16
hundreds though but let's see we got 30
points to go all right now again Oh boom
the note boom oh the note boom is that
is that real yeah that's what he's
playing it's a good bed and different I
struggle against it Oh cuz he's trying
to keep the pawn yeah
that's pretty smart that's the idea
a four put them to the test right to
break it down break it down to the test
all right you do not want to put your
queen on the same diagonal as my guy I'm
gonna make them pay for that I'm gonna
make them pay for that we go the long
con oh now does he see when I'm
threatening my goodness yeah I'll get on
them okay I was worried he was gonna
take your c3 pawn for about 12 moves but
it didn't happen good good good what had
that been good
hey at night take c3 for a long time
Tariq says hi Mike
hello Lou
Jack Jack come on checkmate
Jack made this check mate check plus me
yes all right all right plus eight plus
eight plus say we're moving on up we're
moving on up
all right Larousse loose hopefully it
plays like Denis LaRue and we can get
even closer to 1800 Denis Denis is a not
the fastest chess player who does all
right than that yeah and now if you if
you've seen my blitz mousie in the park
right the guy keeps calling me people's
champ the peoples champ that is a real
title that's a real trophy and the last
round I beat Dennis LaRue for the
further title so I was very excited
about that he declined a threefold
repetition and just went into a losing
in game so that that always helps all
right let's do it let's do I don't know
what you're trying to do but let's just
there's some kind of pawn structure I
don't know exactly what's happening
one more offer one more offer you want
it you know dangerous Rokon b7 dangerous
little Queen takes what's happening
you're on the five all right Jack a file
you got the file got everything you want
it you want it oh they're learning
they're learning don't go into King and
pawn endgame oh I just gave him the file
how ridiculous was that do I absolutely
fun yeah I got that it's tough to tell
oh I could have just taken it all right
but no that's the checkmate threat I saw
it
I still think I got bad checkmate
checkmate I think it's over right
that'll be the match that'll be the mat
all right yeah it's so much closer to
1800 get a goal you see that's why I
always cycles you get a goal and then
BOOM stuff starts happening all right
who else we got sesame Creed you got you
already had your chance
Alex you've got it dream Adi
I just just for fun just for fun he's
never beat me in his life and we played
about 200 times doesn't matter right who
doesn't matter if it's on the screen or
over the board doesn't matter doesn't
matter
I always say I wish this guy was the
number two chess player in the world
because all my wins are like magical
against them and it'd be like oh my god
they would think like this guy is like
the best you'd ever saw mm-hmm
but he's not but he's not yeah right so
it's just like he is indeed a part of
the chess club yes yes he's an official
employee now yeah takes the photos he
takes everybody's picture whether they
wanted her not tog Rafi yeah yeah see if
he can find this one move can he find
his one move nope oh and they be saying
wow this guy is good he compete the
second best player in 17 moves like it's
nothing nothing at all all right who
else we got who else can get us closer
1780s I think there was a guy rated 1787
in here - up top there's a 1737 wants a
rematch forget it he had his chance then
he beat me anyway or maybe I bow you
know I think I beat him yeah this agents
arrow guy comes by the stream a lot and
I want to play him okay cool seen him
around say no more all right you get a
game you get a game this will not take
me to 1800 but it will get me closer
ever so closer to that milestone a
couple more games in here there yep and
I can pass it on to I guess Tuesday hub
will have maybe assurance doing it I
think so maybe
hello Mauricio all right here we go come
a variation that is see if he wants a
draw see if he wants to draw whoa you
just kill a tonight gave the night away
yeah it's too good it's too good gifts
the actually rook oh he has you can only
play them oh no it's falling apart
just check them all day long huh
come all day long
a little check and then that like do it
yes it's never check how hard is it just
throw it in just for fun marchek's more
checks all right you're only up a rook
in two nights
well there goes my night Hawk in one
night but it was worth it it was so
worth it it was look at all that time he
wasted just get castled and have fallen
and don't get back go check me oh look
at that that's the old trick rooks in
the trap the old trick I learned that
from been flying gold actually trap I
was a 1998 state champion but I would
have never known I would have never
known he's out of pieces he's out of
pieces out of pieces just the rest is
technique as they say and I got a lot of
it nothing but
automatically promote to a queen
let's get this rook involved check
checkmate no he knows that little pet
what's that pattern called is I don't
know the name but it's famous that it is
that it comes up a lot
+8 so we're five away let's five away do
it this could do it
let's get let's just nickel and dime
nickel and a pipe up bit by bit the
checkmate pattern with the Queen and the
rook that just showed up
does anybody know the actual name no not
so far okay maybe it's just called good
or something yeah I think they just call
that one winning the game yeah
oh my gosh
Kojak owes giving me a hard time this
game I do not want to lose this game
but I think I got a long time so we are
playing fans send us a 1+0 challenge I
don't think we might not get to use I
think we're gonna we're gonna cut it
when we get to 1800 yep yep that's the
plan we'll get to 1800 and call it a day
Mike doesn't plan on losing so right
yeah I'm not gonna lose to this guy even
though it looks like I might yeah just
not the will to win is too strong this
guy doesn't have the heart for it double
isolate his pawns and all right got the
big check coming up yeah this guy's got
no chance sometimes you just know you're
gonna win even if you're losing bad
whatever got the night got the palm
let's get rid of that pull and as long
as we don't get checkmated somehow which
I don't know how I think it's in the bag
yep it's in the bag we got that pawn oh
he's got my other pawn I'll give him a
check and they'll never see it all right
only one point one point good where's
Adi Chandra again 15600 now he wants you
can't even get you can't even decline
it's all tied down the screen you can
spell okay Ben John you cut you're gonna
head you could have been up there Ben
John could have been up there this guy
looks too good just stole a username
alone
he's the one who wanted a game but this
guy alright you challenge casual the
first time we can get the memo
CRE see you tonight
arty yeah you get points when you beat
these people yeah just as many okay well
let's do it then
up sometime looking good looking good
yep we're on leech s st. Louis Chess
Club I can actually probably link that
to you so be sure to subscribe on the
YouTube there follow on Twitch and you
can also follow the lead chess account
if you want to if you want easy access
so you can send us more challenges when
we stream more doing this four nights a
week Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
be sure to check it out all right I'm
plus three hopefully I get plus four for
beating them and we can call it a day oh
oh I've lost my pawn though at the
Bishan and then I'm gonna lose that
other pawn got to put that Bishop to
work always bringing us his guy owns
like that you got 12 seconds to win it
12 seconds let's not get back row
checkmated that's what Bobby Fischer
teaches just if you read that book
you'll never get back rope shake made it
again if that's if you follow them
maybe I'll maybe I'll finish off with a
back row checkmate I've read part of
that book and I still get background
check maybe I'll never get background
check mated that's how you do it +5 1801
T no all right we're gonna call it a day
we get nod our producer Danny Machuca in
here Danny all right be sure to watch
our stream I've reached on Tuesday and
when that's over with check out Montreal
chest bras versus the st. Louis
Archbishop battle of two first-place
teams it's gonna be great
we're gonna have some top-level players
they'll pie have their top level players
let's see if I've inserted from a jerk
Walter we'll see if our guys are playing
from Gibraltar or maybe they'll bring
out their free agent a nice giri to try
and uh the big gun I don't know it
should be a fun fun match I'm really
excited about that and then the
following week they'll be there battle
warrior lumber one
half of our division will play another
half of their division it'll be game in
ten with a two second increment and
double the points up for grabs so that's
really gonna shake things out the
standings right now since we obliterated
the Webster windmills 11 to 5 just stay
right here actually out of the playoff
window right now so so not only did we
beat them we knocked them currently out
of the playoffs obviously it's week two
and there's a long way to go lots of
points up for grabs in this protest
League season but it's very exciting and
we'll see how it goes so what's up for
you Caleb it any big tournament plans
not too much that's much probably gonna
play the quads tonight quads tonight
yeah I'll just I'm gonna be in the area
I'm heading up to the u s-- at
tournament that should be fun
the u.s. amateur team gonna be playing
that with some people from nice us
amateur team now I that's a good back in
2000 me executive director Tony rich one
of the first employees of the Chess Club
of rakers in ski and Tom Robo we went up
to Chicago to play in the amateur team
and we won and uh and we got one of
those old clocks you know those uh the
hosts of all the ones with the spinning
wheel so that was a lot of fun so if
anybody asked how did my comer get his
job
Tony rich I knew Tony rich they call
them up and say Tony positions it's like
I guess I get something for you so Tony
which genius and I've stuck with them
ever since 10 and a half years so it's
fun hopefully another ten and a half
years at the old chess club and it'll be
fun fun fun right is that so it got any
questions why aren't you playing other
elite players in white Khan's a mic okay
because I am NOT a grandmaster as you
can tell by the stream I'll get people
on the radio on it should be yeah right
can someone send Danny done when will
Ben play the fans AB and Feingold
Grandmaster in original Grandmaster
residence actually has his own chess
club chess club his classic center of
lanta I wonder how he came up with that
name we're cutting it all up look all
right hopefully thanks for watching guys
we'll see you next time maybe maybe how
many viewers there we have I I can't
tell from this screen oh there you are
you be going on YouTube as well it's all
Oh the stream still live though are the
Mike Solt
or the Mike still